hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're gonna
be looking at the neck Benson gambit and
what happens if your opponent takes with
their night instead of the pend the
necklacing game a video I put out
recently was extremely popular everyone
said hey you have to do a video on
Knight taking the gambit as well as if
they decline the game but so this video
is gonna be looking at if the knight
takes the next video we're gonna be
looking at is if black declines if you
haven't seen that video I will have a
link in the description but it starts
out with E 4 E 5 and then f3 knight c6
getting into the Italian game Bishop to
c4 and after Knight f6 d4 could be a few
variations on how we arrived at this but
pawn takes on d4 white castles
continuing to give up material looking
for rapid development Knight takes here
on e4 and then Knight to c3 now really
the most fun way to play this is after
the pawn takes you're gonna bring your
queen up here to d4 and you have a very
strong attack both with your Queen to f7
you're gonna be looking to take the
knight here on e force when you recover
here to e1 get your bishop involved into
the game but they don't have to take
with their pawn so in this video we're
gonna be looking at on the sixth move
what happens if their Knight takes here
on c3 first thing to keep in mind in the
Nachman sin game it doesn't really
matter how they're going to continue is
you want to be very aggressive you want
to get as much major material involved
into the game and attack your opponent
put a lot of pressure on them so in this
case you have two options you could take
with your pawn here you could play your
rook to e1 and definitely want to be
playing rook to e1 you can take the
knight back at some point but you don't
need to right now this puts a lot of
pressure on your opponent right away and
also gets another major piece involved
into the game now they have three main
ways they may decide to defend this one
is Knight to e4 and you may say why
would they even do this they're clearly
just gonna lose this material but
they're pretty much always going to lose
this material here on c3 so the thought
being that yes I know I'm going to lose
this and so if I want to defend with
something like Bishop to e7 after the
rook takes this rook is on a worse
Square than it was before and I don't
allow my
honuts to bring another piece towards
the center of the board so at least
that's the thought if they wanted to do
that we'll go over what happens if they
play that another option would be Knight
to e7 just blocking off knowing that
they are up some material and so they
may just want to turtle up right now and
try to defend as much as possible and
then you also may see Bishop to e7
preparing immediately to castle on the
King side so let's go and take a look at
first one and that is Knight to e4 as
you can imagine we're going to take with
our rook here on e4 attacking the King
more than like you're gonna see Bishop
to e7 they're running out of material as
far as to put in front of this King here
but this is gonna be really nice because
you have another trap that you can use
on your opponent's a bishop to a g5
attacking the bishop and it looks like
the d5 is pretty safe because it's
forking the bishop and the rook here but
you're just gonna go ahead and take with
your Bishop they can't really take
anything except tonight you know queen
take here they're just gonna lose their
queen so Knight taking here on e7 that
makes a lot of sense and then now is the
next trap we almost need that night here
on e7 although that's really the only
move and that's because Bishop to d5 is
a trap you can start to see that White
has a really aggressive position but it
also looks like the bishops hanging here
but it's not because if the Queen takes
here on d5 then rook to d4 is a very
nice trap this Queen is going to fall
there's no way to hold on to it let's
say the Queen comes back here to e6 kind
of the easiest way to see this then you
have a rook to d8 checkmate so they are
going to lose this they could just take
the rook right away Queen captures here
on d4 or something like Bishop to e6
again you're just going to capture this
material right here so that's what
happens if they play that Knight to e4
early on in the game now the next
variation we're going to look at is if
the knight comes to e7 the next
variation we're going to look at is if
the knight comes to e7 now in this pot
we already have our rook here on a1 we
need to start taking this hero back and
then figure out how we want to continue
with our attack so it starts with c3
but from here it's still very difficult
for black to find the best move now
usually playing these gambits when
there's not a lot of time on the clock
so a blitz or a rapid style game usually
you don't want to give your opponent an
hour 2 hours playing some of these crazy
gambits so you definitely could see some
some wild moves like g6 getting ready to
fianchetto their Bishop here to g7
castle on the Kings side but from here
huge mistake Queen takes on d4 attacking
the rook
maybe you look to g8 here and then you
could see Queen to d5 this is
threatening mate here on f7 so maybe
rook to g7 and then it just starts to
fall apart Bishop here to h6 attacking
the rook here so you know all is pretty
much lost for black in this bot that
they could find a much better move but
it's still tough for them to continue
and that's something like d5 well this
opens up for the LightSquared bishop to
get involved into the game it also
attacks the LightSquared bishop for
white since the King hasn't Castle down
the King side so it's still open in the
center of the board here I always like
to keep my pieces attacking and by that
I mean bishop here to b3 because you
could always play bishop here to d3 but
that does block off your queen and
should you still have an attack on this
long diagonal I like to keep it here for
as long as possible doesn't mean I'll
always bring it here but in this case
it's gonna take them a while to get
their Bishop involved into the game and
castle on the King side so this evan
square because early on it's only
defended by the king here is a very very
weak Square now from here they have a
lot of ways they could continue but
let's say Bishop here to e6 they're not
blocking out their pawns so they could
bring it here recognizing this long
diagonal is very very dangerous for them
to deal with but Knight takes on d4 and
all of a sudden Black has a tough time
finding a good move here you know if we
look at how they attack maybe this is
kind of annoying the only way you could
push this way as with pawns but now Y
can actually just take the night here on
e6 while it's defended Queen to h5 is
just deadly if we see g6 then Queen to
e5 this is going to be very very bad you
know you can just start gobbling up
until right here
after the rook moves you can also get
your bishop and involved into the game
at some point you get your rook involved
so many different options that you have
if they don't play g6 maybe they say
yeah I'm just gonna bring my King here
to d7
well Queen f7 and all of a sudden you
can start to see that the position gets
worse and worse for a black can't castle
anymore you're gonna be chasing them
around the board eventually you could
play Bishop here to a3 if you need to
but Queen to e6 the immediate threat
that you have on the board even if they
decide to do something like pawn to g6
getting ready to fianchetto to the Kings
side stopping the Queen coming here to
h5 at some point you can still take with
your knight and if they take right here
it's a little bit different as far as
the threat but Queen to d4 still very
very good attack from white maybe rook
to g8 and all of a sudden rook to e6 and
you can see it's very difficult for
black to hold on to this position now
the only real way for black to play here
but it's still tough is if they bring
their Queen to d7 or d6 now both of
those play very different for white so
we'll look at first if they come here to
a d7 you can still take with your night
here on e6 they're going to recapture
their Queen that would fall so pawn to
e6 and then Queen up here to h4 or
excuse me h5 check if we see g6 queen
comes over here to e5 rook to g8 and you
have a very strong attack you can get
your Bishop and bottom to the game if
you want to to g5 you can just
immediately take here if you want to and
then eventually get your Bishop involved
bring your rook over here to the center
you should have a very good game both
sides equal in material at that point
once you gobble at the pawn and you
should have a very strong attack but if
we come back and see the Queen comes to
d6 plays a little bit different you can
still take with your night here on a6
the main difference is is after they
take right here you don't want to come
to h5 because after pawn to g6 remember
you gave up material to have a strong
attack and now you can't bring your
queen over here to e5 because then
they're just gonna gobble up yes you
could take back but you no longer have
your main pieces you need and now you're
down material without the initiative so
you don't want to do that instead you're
gonna be bringing your queen to g4
this is threatening the attack here on
e6 you could bring a rook up here taking
here on e6 if you want to also puts a
lot of pressure on them as well at some
point you can get your dark square
Bishop involved into the game so this is
how you continue if they play that d5
and then play Bishop here to e6 early on
in that action now if we come back maybe
they don't play d5 right away and we
already talked about what happens if the
bishop comes back here but another
option that you could see is c6
preparing for the pawn to push down
further up the board in this case you're
just gonna take with your queen right
here now they could play d5 and maybe
this is their thought all along I'm
gonna give up those pawns in the center
of the board because I want this solid
pawn structure then I can open up for my
LightSquared Bishop get involved at this
point I would go and bring your bishop
back here to d3 mostly because your
Queens already up here on d4 so it's not
blocking your Queen right away and it
does look like things are starting to
move towards the Kings side of the board
and then you have a more solid structure
of the pawns and the bishop here on it
b3 does not look like it's gonna be
nearly as effective with your Queen your
bishop now both on down on the King side
so that's what happens if they play this
Knight to e7 to stop the check here with
rook to e1 the last version we're gonna
look at is if the bishop comes to e7
pretty logical moves preparing to castle
on the Kings side when you're playing
against a game but you want to get King
safety as fast as possible many times
from here why it's going to take with
their pawn on a c3 and then from here
lots of different variations castle on
the Kings side makes the most sense to
me you bring your Bishop out to protect
your King and then castling is the
safest way to do that and then from here
we're gonna take with our pawn here on
d 4 and then it really depends on how
they want to continue they may feel
confident enough here to start being
pretty aggressive so maybe something
like Bishop here too before knowing that
pawn to c3 is going to be met by Bishop
takes on c3 white doesn't have the
normal night that they can bring from b1
here to c3 but this is actually really
good move from four White's perspective
because Bishop to g5 puts a lot of
pressure on black and we're always
looking to find ways to put pressure on
our opponents when we're playing a game
but their main reason is the Queen
doesn't have a lot of places to go and
they can't play f6 because we have our
bishop here that LightSquared bishop
really a nuisance putting a lot of
pressure on this King side of the board
so from here maybe they play Knight to
e7 because a lot of players don't like
to bring their Bishop out and then bring
it right back to where it was because
they feel like they've wasted two moves
and they have so Knight to e7 but then
we can play the tricky move c3 and this
looks like a mistake because it feels
like well yeah I can just take with my
bishop right here but this bishop is
vitally important to protect this square
here on e7 if they take here then we can
freely take we've taken a knight you can
start to look at the material we've
taken here they have to move their Queen
we can gobble up their real guess they
can take our rook right here but we
bring our Bishop back we took that night
so all of a sudden we have three minor
pieces and we have a very active board
state their light square bishop there
are other rook or not involved into the
game they do have more pawns but we have
more active pieces we should be able to
win this pretty easily now they don't
have to bring their Bishop down to b4
that they could decide okay we're gonna
be a little bit more defensive so maybe
d5 and then from here you know we could
decide to bring our Bishop down to d3 if
we want to continue to be aggressive
here maybe Bishop down to g4 and we play
h3 could have to trade off if we want
soon so that's what happens if they
castle on the Kings side and they don't
have to castle on the King's another
move that's pretty popular is
d 5 and this opens up for the light
script is should be get involved into
the game here and from here I just
recommend Bishop to b5 pinning down the
night they haven't Castle down the
King's idea it so we can still be pretty
aggressive here and they have a few
options that they could play from here
one would be just go ahead and take with
their pawn here on c3 in this case
that's completely fine with us we
already know we can give that material
back but we can play Knight to e5
continue to be aggressive in the board
attacking this night here on a c6 so
that's one option if they don't take
with their pawn right here another
option would just be to castle on the
King side and that's a pretty obvious
one that we can see from here we're just
gonna take with our pawn right here now
they could start to get their bishops
involved they could again feel very safe
so Bishop here to Bishop down here to g4
same thing as before
first I would take with our pawn right
here maybe Queen to d3 trying to be as
aggressive as possible they could play
Bishop over here to be for attacking the
rook now I recommend playing Bishop here
to d2 their queen has more space so you
can't just play the same Queen to g5 and
expect the same results as we saw before
so that's what happens if they castle on
the Kings side now that's all if they're
playing d5 you may not see d5 but it is
very popular you could also see the move
h6 maybe they're familiar with
enactments in game and they know that
the bishop wants to come here to g5 to
some points from here I'm just gonna go
and take with my nights here on d4 if
they want to take that's completely fine
with me I have a pretty active Queen
right here it's attacking this pawn here
on g7 yes I can get my bishop in volume
to the game but because of where this
pawn is on edge 6 more than likely I'm
gonna be bringing my bishop here to a3
this bishop is still being pinned down
by this rook right here on u1 so not
always going to be bringing the bishop
here to 8th
but I do think it makes sense in this
position and then the last if we come
back they may decide to make a mistake
and that is that after the pond takes
they could decide to just take with
their pond right here and that's pretty
mysterious um of the main ways that
could continue because the threat
immediately is the bishop takes here on
f7 the knight takes here on f7 some of
the same lines that you'll see in like
the fried liver attack this is the same
concept and in all of those they always
start from black with d5 because they're
always expecting just the bishop to take
right here on d5 but the problem is if
you do that right away they can just
castle and their king is safe and you no
longer have a strong threat so unlike
the fried liver where you're trying to
gobble up this material here on d5
you're first going to be taking with
your night here on f7 this is very
important because it's attacking the
Queen here on d8 so they they have to
respond to this they're not going to be
looking to castle on the Kings side and
you just take their queen right here on
d8 so they really need to take with
their king and now we can take with our
bishop that they can't recapture because
we're defending it with our queen right
here and so now we check our opponents
and depending on where they go maybe
King to e8 here then we have Bishop here
to a3 and this is so difficult for them
to deal with all we have so many pieces
that are being pinned down so much
attacking lines that we have eventually
we can get our queen involved into the
action if we want to so a lot of her
ways for this to go poorly for black now
instead maybe they play Bishop here to
six we can just take with our rook if we
want to now coming back they may decide
maybe d5 is is not for them maybe in
this spot they look at this and they say
rook to f8 makes a lot of sense what's
nice is we can still take with our night
here on f7 they can't take with their
King it's defended by the bishop and if
they take with their rook then Queen to
h5 is deadly now they may look at this
and say we're threatening with our Queen
here on f7 so we need to stop that maybe
pawn to d5 but Bishop takes on d5 we
still threaten the same thing the bishop
still defended by the Queen here there's
just no good way to to stop this if they
bring their Bishop this square right
here is defended by the rook as well so
we can just continue to gobble up the
material maybe they don't play d5 maybe
they play g6 well this is gonna fail as
well because of the key move very
important to understand this one if you
see it and that is Bishop takes here on
f7
they pretty much need to take with their
King here it doesn't matter if they do
or not they're gonna end up losing the
game here
Queen takes here on it's h7 and they're
gonna lose no matter where they go if
they come back here well this is clearly
just mate and one if they come to after
Queen takes on h7 if they come Queen to
f8 well then we have the bishop get
involved into the game that's gonna be
Czech and then it's gonna be checkmate
pretty soon if they try to bring the
King out
King to f6 probably the best move it's
still gonna be a mate eventually there's
just no way to stop this now that it's
not a forced mate meaning we're not
gonna check them every single time but
there's no way to stop the mate so we
could see G for threatening just g5 at
some point maybe they play e5
then we just push forward with our
Bishop even to get that involved into
the game they take we're just gobbling
out material here rook to e5 you can see
Queens not doing too much it's on this
long diagonal but that's not where we're
attacking the lights where Bishop that
can't do anything right now and so the
king is just pretty much in this awkward
spot where it's gonna be chased around
the entire game rook here to e1 maybe
now they try to open up and get their
lights cribbage bulbs to the game but
we're just gonna completely avoid all
those squares that they can defend on
and at the end of the day it is going to
be checkmate there's no way to to stop
this so maybe
Queen over here to e3 and then
eventually h3 checkmate a lot of
different ways you could do that but
that is the Nachman sin gambit
if they take with their night and this
is the last variation if they take or if
they come here to Bishop here to e7 I
try to make a really in-depth video if
you have watched this whole thing if you
haven't already please like the video I
have been trying to put a lot more time
into these videos to show more
variations so that if you are truly
trying to study these openings and this
is gonna be your go to that you
understand more of the variations more
the thoughts around what both sides are
looking to do and how to attack if they
do certain things but definitely please
like the video if you haven't already
know that the next video coming out is
going to be if they decline the gambit
which come on opponent you always got to
take our our gambits that we provide you
but sometimes they don't so we're gonna
be going over that thank you guys so
much for watching the video and I'll see
you in the next one
you